Go go go go go.
Oh man.
That car wasn't there.
ᴏʜʜʜʜʜʜʜʜ
Is that real?
Yeah. What?!
Hello everyone, we are back with another Stuntmen React.
Where we're gonna break down some of the coolest and perhaps not so cool stunt scenes from your favorite films.
Let's do it. All right, let's go.
See I love this scene. I love how this was like just a horror movie. Like when he's in the wall.
Yeah. Oh my God and the thing is like right here.
ᴬᴴᴴᴴᴴᴴ)jfdw
Trying to fight with a machete would be like the worst experience.
This is it.
ʳʰᴬʷᵂʷ
ᵇʸᴼᴺᵍ-
ᴏʜʜʜʜʜʜ
WHAT
That can double as the reaction.
See how he's like really weaving in and out of everybody.
I mean that was great like he hits him with a machete even though he's got the vest on so it doesn't really hurt him.
Ohʰʰʰ
ᴍʏ
God
So how do they do that? How do they do that? How do they not just murder a man for the sake of our entertainment right there?
I've had different theories. I think it's a dummy.
It looks like a dude there like roto in.
Yeah it does.
Yeah, I think they're both on green screen.
Well, if you see his feet at the end, they don't completely hit the ground. See how they stop?
He's like on a mat or something. Oh you're right. It's for sure green screen added in later.
Good use of VFX. Like when most of it's practical you just don't see it.
ᴼᴴᴴᴴᴴ
I think The Raid's great. Something that like a lot of stuntmen don't love about it is
whenever they need beats in between the beats they go like this with their hands. They're like swimming all the time.
But you know something like The Last Jedi could have used a bit of that like where they're constantly
like on the move in between the beats.
Maybe some people are falling down getting back up and running in as opposed to just posing.
Like stuntmen are constantly trying not to have egg on their face.
A good stuntman is just gonna fill in the gaps but doing something.
I'll just slip and fall and then stand back up and try to be on the same timing.
With the third Batman movie, him and Catwoman are
fighting all the other goons, people are taking reactions when they're hit by nothing.
"Tʜᴇʏ ᴊᴜsᴛ ᴅᴏɴ'ᴛ ᴄᴀʀᴇ."
Look at the guy in the background you see he just falls down.
The far left, like he literally just is like "ᴀʜʜʜ", he forgot that beat I'm just gonna fall down.
Yeah yeah.
No way.
Wow, are you serious?
I think that they were hoping that they would like put it in a Batarang or something like later on.
ᴀʜᴡʜʜAᴀ
Some of the problem with this is also you can't blame it on a stunt coordinator.
Nolan likes to shoot on film so there's no playback and if they do have playback
he just like kind of watches the monitor. It was like. "That felt great. We're done."
Look at that guy!
ᵘʳᴿʰ
ᴜʜWH
Yeah, that was like a foot away.
"It's 2:00 A.M."
"I'm done"
What's the hardest hit you've ever taken?
Oh, I do know that. I dove out a car.
You know, we were supposed to do 25 miles an hour but the guy who's driving is like:
"ᵃᵂʷ ʸᵃ ᵏⁿᵒʷ ;)"
What's the smile mean?
"ғʟᴏᴏʀ ɪᴛ"
"ɴᴏ"
"ɴᴏ NO"
"ᴅᴏɴ'ᴛ ғʟᴏᴏʀ ɪᴛ"
"ᴏᴋᴀʏ FLOOR IT"
"NO"
He's like, "we'll go about 20, 25"
but the thing is that when you're doing some sort of car gag when you get to the like main part you kind
of like lean on it. So you're going 28, or something like that.
We take off, and an effects guy blows the windshield right? And you know it's gonna happen,
but you don't realize how loud it's gonna be and how insane it is when you're in there.
So I'm in the backseat and glass starts blowing all over my face. Now I'm like *sᴜʙsᴄʀɪʙᴇ* can see the point
I'm supposed to go and whip the door open and dive out, and they're like,
"That was amazing! Great! Moving on!"
And everybody starts packing up their stuff. I'm sitting in the corner, I'd knocked the wind outta myself, I'm like,
"ɴɴɴɴɴɴɢɢɢɢɢɢɢɢʜʜʜʜʜʜʜʜ"
"ᴀᴡᴏᴏ ᴏᴡ ᴏᴡ ᴏᴡ ᴀᴡᴏᴏᴏ"
Everybody's like, they're like, "Eric? You good?" And I can't say anything 'cause I can't breathe.
Oh there it is. That's it.
ɢᴜUHHʜʜ
And watch, runs out.
Hoo, man.
Savage. Yeah, dude you bounced! So up on adrenaline. Oh, yeah. I just knew I didn't want to screw it up.
Like they're blowing everything up and the next day every molecule in my body hurt.
That sounds about right. I love the description that everyone just packs up.
Like, it's like, "ᴏPᴇ, ɢᴏᴛ ɪᴛ, ᴏᴘᴇ ɴʏᴜʜʜ"
Everyone just moves on. They don't check on the stunt guy. Like he lands in the box and it's like, "alright we're good!"
"ᴀᴡᴏᴏ ᴏᴡ ᴏᴡ ᴏᴡ ᴀᴡᴏᴏᴏ"
You know the guy went all the over one take? Yeah. That was a gnarly fall.
Yeah, he definitely did. Only in a movie directed by a stuntman would anybody be like:
"Yeah, we're gonna use the car to fight all the bad guys."
Like there's no, everybody be lik- oh look at that. That's awesome. Dang how great is that?
Can you roll that back a little bit? So this guy literally had to
initiate a slide.
Before he hits the ramp so that then when he launches through the air
he's going sideways and then had to kind of gather it up as it slides across the ground
bouncing and not hit the camera that's tracking across. Oh, you're right. Look at that!
Okay, the guy's like, "ᴏH ɢᴏ ɢᴏ ɢᴏ ɢᴏ ɢᴏ!"
Yeah, there's a guy in the pursuing vehicle is like *sᴜʙsᴄʀɪʙᴇ*. That's crazy.
I had no idea it such a technical shot. Look at the guy inside bouncing up and down.
I mean, we've talked a lot about Tom Cruise, but you know, Keanu Reeves,
he did a lot of this driving stuff himself.
Like once his doors come off you get a lot of great shots of him in there sliding the car.
You know interacting with the camera, which is I mean, just action gold. Yeah, like that hit right there.
I mean he's doing that. Do they use kit cars for that or are they destroying that really nice car?
I'm sure that they made a kit car out of it. A kit car's where they get something like a
Lamborghini that would be way too expensive to crash and they remake the body out of stuff
that isn't carbon fiber that may look like it and they're also putting an engine in it that could be a Civic.
"This is a 1989
ʜOɴDᴀ CɪVɪᴄ"
They can crash that car. Although it'll still work and drive they can crash it without the cost.
So that's him right there. Yeah, look at that. Dude, that's crazy.
Well, he also slid into that position and then was able to maintain it.
That's awesome, I love that. That was great.
It's probably all practical too I'm assuming.
Oh, that's crazy too. So they did a little gag where they yanked the car with a wire.
Yeah. And you know Keanu just gets shot out there.
But he comes so close to that back wheel. Even though it looks like he's close to the back tire
I think you still probably could have pulled it off with the limit line
so that the back wheels couldn't possibly touch him.
They certainly did that with a stuntman a couple of times and they're like, "look it's gonna land here."
And Keanu's a tough son of a bitch, so I think he did that. I feel like the-
Ooh oh snap. So how'd do you not break your knees when that happens?
He knows he's gonna get hit so he takes his uh, one of his feet and kind of gets it up.
Oh his legs never actually get touched.
Yeah, so he knows it's gonna happen.
He lifts that one leg and then once your weight kind of hits it, it takes your other leg up.
Watch, he hits the break.
ʙᴏᴏᴘ
Spits him off.
I feel like the style of fighting in John Wick is a bit slower and chunkier
but really brutal, you know more realistic. It is. See how he's yankin' him with his with his jacket?
I mean that is what you would actually do and trying to get somebody off
balance or control their weight or their body or where you want them to go.
Although it doesn't always look as sexy as like something in The Raid where they're popping constantly.
John Wick is like stunt 𝓹𝓸𝓻𝓷.
Basically.
Chad Stahelski was Keanu Reeves' stunt double throughout The Matrix.
You know there's the one scene where Agent Smith blasts Neo when they're in the subway fight.
And he goes flying back and he hits like a subway like ticket taking thing. He smashes through it.
Well, if you watch it, he doesn't break it and just head just get slammed like this.
He took some gnarly hits in The Matrix.
Chad's been amazing with these films and I think that you get some really great stuff that most directors wouldn't be able to pull off.
Do you do a lot of car stuff? I've definitely done a decent amount of driving.
I know some of the guys that do some of The Fast and the Furious stuff and those guys are like true car guys.
You know they can literally slide it and stop on a dime, it's unbelievable.
I feel like The Fast and the Furious franchise like started out with all good intentions and was pretty cool.
They were doing something different which stretched reality just a smidge. Yeah, now it's just like Hot Wheels. Like now it's like a video game.
Yeah. Can you look up the The Fast and the Furious where they're dragging the safe?
Man. Is that real? Yeah. What?! This is real and that's why it looks really good.
ᴡᴏᴏ
What they did is I know the guys that did this and
that vault that they're dragging through the street is a car.
"But what I did is I took a pickup truck and I cut the entire
middle half out of it from the back of the front wheels to the front of the back wheels,
we took that out and we welded it back together
so all it has is an engine, front wheels, and back wheels and a seat and that's essentially it."
And there is another guy that's back there like looking through like a peephole.
And he is literally like
sliding the car, like drifting this car with the bank vault around it. Are you kidding me?
Yeah, 'cause those wires and everything are all there. So he's you know,
he's keeping up with these guys and
driving this thing through the streets.
Dude, the visual of there being a car inside that bank vault and just the dude driving it.
What a great idea, like if you were like, "I want to drag this vault through the street," like would you have thought to have a human in there driving it?
And if it was all CG it wouldn't feel the same. You just can tell.
Eric, you've opened up a window here that we otherwise wouldn't have.
And I really thank you for coming out here and sharing that all with us.
Oh yeah, thank you for having me. It's lot of fun to break this stuff down with you guys.
Now people have questions about the craft and they're trying to get into this. Would you recommend they shoot you a message?
Yeah, absolutely! I try to answer everybody. Believe it or not, I'm not very famous.
I've answered a lot of questions in the past and I'm always happy to.
if you have stunts that you have questions about like whether it's like, "this thing was crazy I want you guys to watch it,"
or like, "how the heck did they do this?"
Leave a comment down below if you want us to react to it in the future and we'll definitely take a look.
We can't wait to read the suggestions that you guys have!